[Music]
welcome everybody to take control of
your multi cluster multi tenant
kubernetes workloads this is a talk
we're gonna give today about dealing
with kubernetes in kind of enterprise
deployments where you've got lots of
clusters lots of tenants and in
particular we're going to talk about the
gke policy management alpha that we
announced here today and we'll be
demoing that in the end my name is John
Murray I'm a product manager with Google
cloud with me is going to be ray Colleen
who's one of the lead engineers on the
project so upfront we're gonna go
through some of the principles that we
were looking at we're trying to deal
with some of the problems around
managing multiple kubernetes clusters
and dealing with the multi tendency
issues that arise from that when you're
thinking about policies access control
quota limitations and those sorts of
things us we'll walk through that rail
spend some time walking through the
architecture and some of the features
that we have that we reviewing here in
the alpha and then we'll do a demo for
you at the end so to start it off I want
to talk about just generally the
problems that we see when we talk to
customers who are really looking to
scale up their kubernetes deployments
and these are administrative problems
right there the problems of operators in
dealing with how do you get a bunch of
development teams on to kubernetes
infrastructure how do you make them
productive while ensuring that things
are secure and that you're keeping an
eye on all the administrative things so
when people start out with kubernetes
this is usually what we see these sort
of cluster per tenant scenarios where
you have one tenant in this case write a
dev team the blue team and they want to
play around with kubernetes they want to
experiment with it so they go and spin
up a cluster and that very easy on gke
it's also very easy to spin it up using
some tooling or to work with any other
cloud provider and once you have
multiple people doing this now you have
a number of these cluster pertinent
scenarios within your company you have
one tenant they have their own cluster
they start running their pods in the
default namespace and that's fine they
have isolation because that cluster is
the boundary for them and it's not
necessarily administrative hassle but if
there's scales and you've got a hundred
of these clusters running with a hundred
different tenants all running their
clusters different ways then it's hard
to think about normalizing things like
access control across them it's hard to
deal with upgrades it's hard to deal
with versioning it's hard to deal with
all the sorts of administrative tasks
that you have to manage so the next
phase the evolution and we see people go
through is that they take that tenant
and they provision them a namespace
across multiple clusters and so now
you've got say three clusters running
maybe you're doing that because you need
clusters in each region close to where
your users or your workloads are maybe
you're doing it for redundancy there's a
number of regions why you might want
multiple clusters if we give a namespace
to the blue team each one of those
clusters then they can run their pods
there and we can attach policies and to
access control quota control Network
policies etc at the namespace or at the
cluster level is to kind of normalize
that where it really gets tricky is when
you have multiple tenants across
multiple clusters so in this case I've
got two tenants a blue team and a green
team each with their own namespace in
all my clusters but in a real life
scenario you may have hundreds of these
tenant teams each with their own
namespace and you may have dozens of
these clusters and so the scalability
problem becomes in how do you manage the
policies across all of these because
each of these kubernetes clusters is
somewhat of an island when you're
talking about policy management setting
up the namespace definitions setting up
role based access controls for each of
these namespaces and ensuring that each
of the namespaces looks the same across
all the clusters
so your development teams don't have to
deal with variance across that workspace
and today people are managing that in a
number of ways but it's a lot and so we
see over and over again as people scale
up from experimenting through kubernetes
to dealing with it at scale this is a
point that they end up with and maybe
they try to manage it with scripts
maybe they build their own tooling but
it's something that we wanted to take a
look at and say can we as Google come up
with something for the kubernetes
community that helps deal with this
particular problem so that's what we're
going to talk about with you guys today
before we get into the nitty-gritty of
the details about what we've built and
what we're doing in the Alpha I just
want to talk about a couple of design
principles that we use when we were
looking through how to deal with this
problem so the first one is that we
didn't want kubernetes
clusters to be Islands right now there's
very little Federation support in
kubernetes and so if you're running
dozens of clusters you're often
interacting with them one by one loading
them all up into the context of your
cube Caudill and switching around
scripting against that but automation
here is really the only way to manage
this is the same way across a lot of
clusters so we wanted to build tooling
that works in this cross cluster
environment and provide some
centralization so that you don't repeat
yourself over and over again when
applying policies the other thing we
want to do is create a clear separation
between infrastructure and tenancy so
the analogy here is like an apartment
building right you start with an empty
apartment building like an empty cluster
and you need to set it up so that you
can bring people in and have them move
into the apartments and that's things
like you know setting up the
infrastructure the plumbing the heating
the electricity but it's also setting up
a lease right what are the terms of your
tenancy what are you allowed to do
you're not allowed to play death metal
at 2:00 in the morning you're not
allowed to hang out you know naked in
the hallways you need to be a good
tenant but within the the concept of you
know within the constraints
your apartment you're allowed to do
whatever you want you can hang up
whatever posters you want we're not
gonna tell you what couch color you need
to do we create a safe environment for
you where things are clearly delineated
the administrative things are for
administrators and dev teams are freed
up to do what they need to do in an
agile way and the last principle is
policy workflow so we can automate
policies we can centralize policy
management but we want to make the
actual application those policies easy
to manage and oftentimes when you're
talking about scaled up infrastructure
you've got a team of people who are
doing administrative stuff setting
policies and so we wanted to build
workflow around the changes that happen
around the definition of those policies
so that administrators could cooperate
with one another review policy changes
think about policy changes in the same
way that you think about code you can
roll them back you can do reviews you
can edit them and have auditability
around changes that are made there a lot
of the things that we take for granted
we're talking about source control we
wanted to bring some of that goodness to
policy management so those things we
were thinking about as we were looking
at building something we spent the last
couple months here getting it ready and
bringing out to alpha so please welcome
to the stage ray Colleen my colleague
he's an engineer on the project and he's
going to walk you through kubernetes
policy management Thanks thank you John
and again I'm ray Colleen and I'm a
software engineer who thinks a lot about
policy management on kubernetes so today
we're gonna actually be getting into
talk about what did we do from this
alpha and what are we gonna be doing
kind of going forward with this and
where do we see it going and how
hopefully it can help you so the first
thing I want to say is that this is just
one part of a much bigger story that
we've presented here at next and
importantly with the hybrid story you'll
see here that policy management which is
down at the bottom fits into the overall
kind of you know on-prem gke managed
isseo
want to have a way of dealing with all
these things from a policy perspective
or as the analogy that that John used
thinking about the building owner in
this case who's trying to lease out
these these apartments which have all of
these particular particular features so
when we think about policy management
specifically we're thinking about
essentially defined policies in a source
of truth so you want one place to go
look at that you can say here is all of
the tenants in my environment across all
of my clusters and that know that when
you see when you submit and put changes
in that source of truth then it applies
across all of your clusters and so we're
really doubling down as namespaces in
kubernetes as the as the minimum level
of tenancy for defining this and and you
can think about it in terms of the
analogy is that tenant our name spaces
are really those apartments that you're
leasing out and so with this central
policy store you can manage things like
our back and quota policy and more right
and that more is is coming okay so I
mentioned the idea of sources of truth
what I'm gonna try to do now is detail
kind of how the components of gke policy
management work and kind of the concepts
that we've we've introduced so it starts
with the idea of a source of truth which
is that place where your policies are
defined now in the Alpha to talk about
two particular sources of truth that we
support today but the intention is is to
be able to build arbitrary sources of
truth to be to meet customers where they
are and we know a lot of our customers
end up creating their own policy stores
and then want to figure out how to make
that work with their hybrid environments
and so we've designed that with this in
mind where one's gonna be able to write
a component to read arbitrary sources of
truth and so what we've enabled in the
source of truth is the concept of
hierarchy so now today in kubernetes
namespaces are flat and then there's a
cluster on top of it and you can
basically set a cluster wide policy or
you can set a per name space policy but
in many organizations they want to
actually group namespaces and then apply
policies to a subset of namespaces
so in GK policy management we support
the concept of a group of namespaces
that have common are back
and common quota policies and so with
that what we've written what so we have
that as the source of truth and then
within each cluster so every cluster
that's being managed by GK policy
management there's a set of components
controllers that we install as part of
the GK policy mansions GK policy
management install and so I'm gonna
first talk about the idea of a policy
importer and so what the policy importer
is responsible for is reaching out to
that source of truth whether it be get
whether it be GCP whether it be a my
sequel database and reading the policy
data and putting it into the cluster as
a set of CDs or kubernetes basically
objects that represent the data and then
there's the sinker component which reads
those and is able to talk to the
kubernetes api server to create those
objects so we would manage things like
namespaces our back policy resource
quota objects possibly limit ranges you
know there's a bunch of objects and and
the idea of that separation is that the
policy important owes how to speak to
different sources of truth and the N and
normalizes it to a format we understand
and then the sinker reads that format
and realizes the changes on the cluster
and then I mentioned that we support
hierarchical quota
well again inside of true Bernays today
there is no hierarchy it's just flat
namespaces so we wrote our own admission
controller which understands hierarchy
and can support over subscription and so
now when you do you know create pods and
whatnot you actually can control the
number of CPUs at a group of namespaces
level ok so now I'm going to talk a
little bit more about our sources of
truth that we shipped in the alpha so in
the alpha we have get and we have GCP as
a source of truth and so I'm gonna start
talking about get the reason we chose
get is because git ops turns out to be a
way that a lot of organizations think
about managing policy and the advantages
here get to some of the idea of the
workflow that John spoke about code
tooling like it supports the idea of pre
commits you can do continuous
integration right you can do code
reviews and so now you can think of like
you know creating an AR back policy as a
proposal or a a merge request and then
someone then can approve it and once it
gets integrated and then once it gets
integrated we automat
we sink it down to the cluster and apply
it so this lets you use a workflow and
introduce arbitrary levels of policy and
meta policy into your management so
specifically with the git source of
truth we've created our own directory
format which represents the hierarchy
and effectively we use the file system
which is a very good natural natural way
to represent hierarchy and you'll see
here in this example on the right where
you have food corp which is the root of
the organization and then underneath
that you have online and on lines a
department and within online you can
have a series of namespaces and
namespaces and you also can have an are
back binding the mo and so what we do is
we use the same the amel you use in
queue cuddle so it's the same exact type
of thing you write if you were writing
cube cuddle except you're checking it
into a repo and because it has the
hierarchy will actually take those are
back policies and we flatten them to
create the bindings in each namespace
giving the online admin the ability to
see shipping at back-end and shipping
products cetera
okay now what we also have is the
concept of a vetting tool that make sure
that the integrity of this filesystem
stays right so if you check in random
stuff for example if you create a
directory under a namespace that's not
allowed and so for us what's really
important is the question of will it
blend or will it apply right the answer
should always be yes and every time that
question is asked it's always yes and so
this is a really big deal in policy as
code because you don't want to check
things in that get to the end of the
pipeline and fail because when that
happens you're now stuck with a
situation where you're getting sort of
truth' no longer represents the reality
on the clusters and then operator right
there if they don't do anything that
stays persistent and then you don't have
a good idea of what's what and then or
you have to revert the change and figure
out what happens so we spent a bunch of
time creating a vetting tool that allows
that make sure that the integrity of
that tree is is done and that's part of
the the Alpha so anyways once you commit
this stuff is connected to and grabbed
by each cluster and the policies are
applied okay now I want to talk about
our other source of truth which is GCP
so within GCP there's a there's a
hierarchy and it's defined through the
cloud resource manager and so the cloud
resource manager
the concept of an organization which is
the root it has GCP folders which are
basically sub organizations and projects
now projects in GCP are the minimum
level of tenancy and namespaces in
kubernetes are the minimum level of
tenancy so they have a really nice
relationship one-to-one with each other
and so what we've done here is we've
said okay with an API that we're also
putting out with the Alpha launch you
can associate a namespace with the
project and so now what happens is is
that if you set IM policies and you use
cloud for i am and you set it on a
project and you associate that project
with the name space we will synchronize
the IAM policy to an our back policy on
the cluster so you can manage all of
your access control policies whether it
be for using cloud sequel or whether
it's using kubernetes in the same place
and this even works whether you're using
gke
or using kubernetes on GC or you've been
using amazon or another you know on Prem
cloud provider you can use the DCP
hierarchy with I am to manage those
those workloads and so what this thing
does is wanted its converts I on
policies to our backs but also does a
compilation using the GCP cloud resource
manager hierarchy to provide the ability
to do the subdivision of namespace
management okay so with that I'm gonna
take you back to John who will do a
demonstration of what I just talked
about
okay before I get into the demo I just
want to set the stage a little bit so
ratioed you would get example a little
bit earlier that's what I'm gonna walk
through here and just kind of show you
how I define some namespaces how I set
up tenants so that they can deploy their
pods on the clusters we'll talk a little
bit about controlling quota particularly
controlling quota across namespaces and
and then we'll set up a new namespace
for a new tenant just to show you what
that looks like we'll do it across a
couple clusters the example we're gonna
walk through here is foo Corp foo Corp
has today right now an online division
and the online division has dev staging
and prod set up his namespaces on all
that's the policy file that we'll be
applying here and then we've got kind of
policies attached it at different levels
the hierarchy here up at the top we've
got admin policies so that we can view
the pods set pod security policy across
the entire organization and then down at
the level of the namespace tenants will
define the namespaces themselves set up
some shared resource quota as well as
namespace level quota and we'll set up a
pod crater role so our dev team can show
up and do what they do best which is
deploy applications can we cut over to
the demo okay great all right so what
you're seeing here is team accession
I've got a watch on the right side
that's a local repository or local
version of the repository it's actually
hosted on github and shows kind of the
basic high-level policies that I've got
applied across my company right now so
none of the namespace structure is in
there we don't any namespaces specific
to our development I'm watching two
clusters here at the bottom just listing
out the namespaces and that's just the
the basic stuff that comes with
kubernetes as well as our agents that
are installed locally on the clusters so
let's get started I'm going to look at
this cluster here on the left with Q
cuttle and now I'm going to bring in a
bunch of policies so I'm just copying
these locally from one directory to
another on my machine and you can see
from the tree that now we're gonna add
this online division to FoodCorps
underneath online there you've got
shipping out back-end which is our
service which has three namespaces dev
prod and staging all those have
namespace definitions so they're just
standard yeah Mille as well as some role
bindings so we've got the pod creator
role binding here you notice that's at a
level above the namespaces so that pod
creator role binding will apply to all
three of those names
spaces and the same is true the quota
there so we'll be enforcing that quota
as a shared pool of resources across the
three namespaces and then we've got kind
of namespace level roll bindings here
for job creator and a namespace level
rule to find there so that's kind of the
initial policy state that I want on my
clusters I'm gonna go ahead and make a
commit here up to github to initialize
some of those policies and push it out
okay so that's going up to the cloud
being applied and you can see there
locally cluster one picked it up and
cluster two is a couple seconds behind
but it also picked it up so what
happened there is the pods that we've
installed with our system on these
individual clusters are constantly
pulling that repository pulling down the
whole thing interpreting the hierarchy
they're flattening it out into
kubernetes namespaces and making all the
policy applications so now I've got all
of my namespaces set up let's go take a
look at it
so if I look at one of these rule
bindings and this is the pod creator
role binding here that I've got set up
kind of at an intermediate level
shipping app back-end if I look at that
definition it's pretty simple it's
giving me pod creator role which allows
me to deploy pods in the cluster and
we're buying that to our developer here
Alice at food Corp so that's going to
give Alice the ability to do whatever
she needs to do to manage her
application across those three
namespaces if you look at the actual
roll bindings on the cluster you can see
in shipping dev right that insects got
three roll bindings so this is the
flattened out version of the hierarchy
that we have in our repository it's got
the food court viewers which is up at
the top to find it's got the pod creator
role binding that we were just talking
about and it's got a namespace specific
role binding and job creators so that's
what our system is doing is flattening
that out and apply
to all the namespaces across all the
clusters and if we want to test that out
we can pretend we're Alice and try to
get some secrets out of kubernetes pod
create a rule bunny does not give me
access to those secrets and so that
fails but if I try to get the pods that
succeeds I know I don't have any pods
but it didn't fail the off child so
let's look at the quota this is the
quota file that's in shipping out
back-end so it's up there at the
intermediate level of the hierarchy and
this is a quota definition that is
shared by these three namespaces it's a
pretty simple quota gamal three pods one
core and one Giga memory so let's test
that I'm gonna create a pod here with my
exciting new application busybox sleep
and I'm gonna ask for about 80% of a
processor so that goes through no
problem it's less than the shared quota
and now I'm eating up 80% of that shared
quota with the deployment in the
namespace shipping prop so what happens
if I want to deploy in one of the sister
namespaces here shipping dev same image
but now I'm gonna ask for 30% so I ask
for 80% before I'm asking for 30% now
for those of you who haven't been able
to do the math that's more than one CPU
and so this should fail and it does and
what's happening here is we're
evaluating the quota at the shipping dev
level which passes and then we're going
up a level in the hierarchy and serially
evaluating the quota that's shared
across all three of these namespaces and
that's where this fails and so you can
set quota in the hierarchy at an
arbitrary number of levels here and
we'll enforce it up the chain and we
think this is a pretty cool way to deal
with the fact that kubernetes only
natively manages resource quota Conniff
at the namespace level if you
have sub-team namespaces but you don't
want to deal with portioning out pools
of quota across them this is one way you
can accomplish it and just to show you
that does actually work we'll try the
same application here but we'll ask for
only 10% and that goes through so that's
quota let's set up a new namespace so
let's say we've got a new dev team who
wants to come onto the kubernetes
deployments that we've got and we they
want a a home on all of our clusters
that's fairly simple here all I have to
do is make them a directory need to find
them a namespace so I'm gonna make a
directory locally which you should see
pop into my tree here so this is
shipping up front ends and we'll give
the front end team a home now that's an
empty directory so I've got to give them
a namespace definition and we'll just
set up a simple namespace for them in
Yammer so I've got my directory I've got
my mo and I'm gonna commit that and push
it up to the cloud
if you're looking at the bottom there at
my clusters they should pick up that
change and you'll see the shipping out
front-end namespace there six seconds
five seconds just showing up on the
clusters the great thing about this is
I'm only running two clusters here but
because all the clusters are pulling
down this you can run this system with
one central repository and you know as
long as that repository can handle the
QPS you can scale this out to as many
clusters as you want so let's take a
look at some of these role bindings for
shipping out front end so you can see
it's got a flattened out role binding
from fruit Court viewers that's fine but
it's not gonna let anybody on the
development team do anything so we need
to set up a role binding for Alice our
developer so she can get into the
front-end namespace and start deploying
some of our front-end applications so
way I'm gonna do that is not to go and
define a separate role binding for Alice
because she's already got a troll
binding for pod creation what I'm gonna
do is take the existing role binding so
that's the one it's shipping out back
end here this pod create a role binding
and I'm just gonna move that up a level
in the hierarchy so I'm going to take
that binding and just say okay actually
Alice should have pod creation across
everything below online in my tree so if
I just move that up one directory by
moving the file around that should be
sufficient to give Alice the privileges
that she needs so I'll push that change
and then if I go look at the roll
bindings on shipping app front-end I
should see hopefully Alice's new
permission pop in and there it is four
seconds ago online pod creators so just
by moving that roll binding around in my
repository now it applies to a whole
different set of namespaces and my
developers are good to go
Alice can go and do what she needs to do
in terms of deployment and so that's the
basics of this you see the quota can be
managed across different hierarchies you
can see you know a sane way to kind of
define things once and do it in a way
that fits the hierarchy of larger teams
and and doing things in the gate way
here really allows you to do the get ops
experience of making these commits
validating them potentially doing a pull
request and a review and kind of saying
lis checking that across team members to
make sure that everybody's happy with
them before they're applied and pulled
down to the clusters and then you're
only doing it once and because the
automation that's available here as well
as some of the monitoring and logging
that we have that lets you know that
changes actually get propagate you only
have to do it once and if you have made
a mistake right if you did apply some
policies that are problematic for you
all you have to do is roll back we've
got the full history here because it's
in a code repository so I can revert all
those changes that I made roll them back
and push that up to the cloud and I'm
back where I started
it'll kill all of my namespaces because
they're managed by Nomos get rid of all
those deployments and put me back into a
state that allows me to you know roll
back to an earlier vetted version my
central policy management and so that's
our demo
we switch back to the slides
that's so that's basically what we've
got for you guys today the Alpha is now
open for participation if you're
interested in participating that's the
link there QR code will take you to the
same place if you take a picture of it
with your phone there's just a brief
form there we're trying to bring as many
people in as we can and so fill that out
let us know if you're interested okay
well thanks a lot for joining us guys
they will be around and have a great
conference
[Music]